i was just talking to somebody about
this last week about like
every four years or eight years some
[ __ ] will start to get done and then and
then whoever gets whoever gets elected
will try to undo whatever the last guy
did
which is actually a good thing it's just
a well i guess it depends right because
let's say
you're on the cusp of getting something
historically dope done i don't know what
it might be whatever it's
whatever right something that's gonna
help a lot of people free care whatever
it is
then another guy gets elected and then
they undo all it just feels like a cycle
of like because it is very cyclical as
to which party is in right
it's like it'll be eight years of a
democrat and then it'll be
eight years of george w bush then it's
eight years of obama then trump you know
what i mean so
it just feels like uh a bureaucracy
cycle of like it is and as much as
as ugly as it is and as much as people
are so hot and vitriol about who's in
and who's not this is the best case
scenario for everybody for society in
the world for civilization yeah because
we don't they talk about corruption
voter fraud yes every election is fraud
but that's to be expected
if i was trying to run for president i'm
going to be trying to cheat too like i
want yeah
well i think all that like like you said
every election there's voter fraud yeah
but every election ever is not it's not
total corruption
total corruption is venezuela is when
[ __ ] went by 90
you know what i'm saying
you will never find even 55
45 in america it's always a a percentile
or two off and that's perfect people
should be appreciative of that you know
what i'm saying so
yeah everybody hate
for half the country to hate the
president and love the president each
time whichever way is the best case
scenario that's fair you know
yeah i think uh we think of a country
that's like a first world country russia
russia is like a big country that's not
like some [ __ ] third world place it's
very they have mcdonald's they have
starbucks well not anymore apparently
they're gutting all the mcdonald's out
there but if you think about a place
like russia russia is a first world
country
but
yeah it's a very
joe biden's not [ __ ] getting people
killed or running against them and
donald trump wasn't getting people
killed or running against him nobody's
afraid of joe biden
i mean that's fair nobody's afraid of
joe bite sleepy joe yeah